good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 209 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 209 is to be held in a 0.5 by 0.5 by
0.5 meter pressure sealed storage locker
insulated to prevent any potential aroma
from release to the surrounding area
access to SCP 209 is limited to a single
class two or higher staff member or any
transport a standard security detail
should accompany any transport of a CP
209 at a distance of at least 23 meters
no more than one human subject of any
classification should be within the
minimum safe distance of 20 meters of
SCP 209 at any time outside of a
research trial setting as current
hypotheses regarding the function of SCP
209 s active phase indicate enticement
to use through a factory manipulation of
some kind any staff assigned to the
research trial or security detail should
be equipped with personal air filtration
devices rated at foundation standards of
at least Euclid 3h EPA filter oil
resistant research has approved the use
of the prototype modular keycard system
as see passport for SCP 209 storage
locking mechanism the key card for
scp-294 egde is modified with a
proximity alarm and deactivation
protocol to enforce the single user only
containment mandate if more than one
human subject is detected in the
proximity of both the keycard device and
lock a level 1 containment breach alarm
will be sounded in the locking system
disabled to prevent removal of SCP 209
from its storage locker
description SCP 209 appears to be a
single malt scotch tumbler 10
centimeters in height and with an 8
centimeter diameter at its widest point
the tumbler shows no manufacturer's
marks but does indicate signs of
moderate to heavy use and light wear
including a small chip missing from the
rim but not in the possession of a human
subject the tumbler it contains
approximately 88 to 91 milliliters
roughly three ounces of an unknown
golden brown translucent liquid this
liquid cannot be siphoned spilled
drained evaporated or otherwise removed
from SCP 209 by any means other than a
human subject taking hold of the tumbler
and consuming the liquid all activators
subjects debriefed following a sampling
of the liquid produced by a CP 209
reported to be alcoholic in nature and
providing a sense of warmth self
assurance and general well-being this
effect has proven to be highly addictive
with methadone therapy currently holding
the highest rates of success for
detoxification from SCP 209 s effects
for SCP 209 to enter its active phase
three conditions must be met
number one at least two human subjects
must be within 20 meters of SCP 209
number two at least one of the human
subjects must have a normal functioning
sense of smell and detect SCP 209 s
aroma a nas m'q test subjects have been
unable to initiate the active phase
number three the subject who first
detected the odor of SCP 209 must take
possession of the tumbler and consume
any amount of liquid within it
hereafter activator subject once these
conditions are met SCP 209 enters its
active phase the activator subject will
immediately seek a relaxing or
comfortable position in which to finish
the liquid in SCP 209 at
leisurely pace any other human subject
within 20 metres of the activators
subject hereafter prey subject will be
locked into two distinct physical
parameters for the duration of the
active phase number one prey subjects
will be physically incapable of moving
more than 20 meters away from the
activator once ingestion has begun
number two prey subjects will be
physically incapable of moving closer
than one meter to the activator once
ingestion has begun all current attempts
at moving any prey subject beyond these
boundaries while living have met with
failure any human subject entering the
20 meters fear of scp-294
and prey subjects have been established
are not affected any descriptive word or
phrase used in reference to scp-2950
phase will physically reflect upon the
prey subject in a variety of ways see
experiment logs 209 - 6.2 through 209 -
33.8 or details activator subjects seem
aware of both the boundary restrictions
imposed on prey subjects as well as the
physical effect of their descriptive
language but no matter the scale of
physical harm or distress inflicted upon
prey subject activators subjects seem to
retain a light amused demeanor it is
theorized that the effects SCP 209
inflicts on prey subjects is intended as
a form of entertainment for the
activators subject to enjoy while
experiencing SCP 209 6 when the
activators subject has consumed all the
liquid within SCP 209 both boundary
parameters are nullified
if still capable of motion former prey
subjects can and do flee the area with
as much speed as possible the activators
subject will immediately become infused
by the now-empty
SCP 209 an attempt to refill it with any
available liquid if the activator is
successful in filling SCP 209 with
approximately 88 to 91 milliliters of
any liquid it will transmute into
another glass of golden-brown
translucent alcohol and the cycle begins
again provided there is another
potential prey subject in range
if prey subjects or others disable or
remove SCP 209 from the activator before
they are able to quote refill it CP 209
will exit the active phase and remain
empty and inert for approximately 79
hours before refilling itself by unknown
means to potentially begin a new active
phase addendum experiment log 209 -
18.43 Class D subjects appropriated for
testing 25 by 25 by 6 meter room
furnished with a single steel folding
chair and a CP 209 activator subject
designated d ACT pray subjects
designated d pray 1d pray to log begins
122 seconds following D Act ingestion of
SCP 209 122 seconds d ACT seats himself
in the single chair provided in the room
D pray one approaches D Act D pray 2
begins exploring the rooms boundaries
188 seconds D pray one discovers the
inner boundary and is unable to approach
D act 194 seconds D pray two discovers
the outer boundary and is unable to
reach the eastern wall 227 seconds d
pray one begins shouting obscenities and
attempts to strike D in it no effect D
pray 2 attempts to map the outer
boundary 255 seconds D Act describes SCP
209 as smoky 258 seconds D pray 1 begins
coughing violently D prayed 2 approaches
284 seconds D pray 1 collapses wracked
with violent coughs an unknown black
smoke like gas is expelled from his
mouth with each cough D pray two
attempts to approach D act 299 seconds D
Act describes SCP 209 as smooth 302
seconds D pray 2 appears to begin
sweating profusely D pray 1 continues
coughing spasms expulsion of smoke like
substance continues from mouth nose and
eyes 363 seconds D pray to exuding a
thick layer of viscous near frictionless
substance from all pores substance has
eroded clothing and apparently the first
layer of epidermis D pray to is unable
to remain standing Falls and attempts to
staunch the flow of the unknown
substance from his pores D pray one
apparently expired smoke like substance
continues to vent from mouth nose and
eyes the act
plots intermittently
484 seconds viscous substance exuded
from Despres - has eroded two additional
layers of skin wounds approximate -
second and third degree burns deep rate
- expresses desire to be terminated
request denied
the active peers fixated on the
remaining liquid of SCP 209 522 seconds
deep rate to expires substance appears
to cease exude impor one ceases to expel
smoke like substance D act continues
drinking SCP 209 948 seconds D act
consumes the last of SCP 209 immediately
stands and rushes to the body of D prey
one begins clawing at the corpse with
left hand while maintaining hold of SCP
209 with the right 954 seconds
researchers determine that D act is
attempting to refill a CP 209 with the
blood from the corpse of Despres one per
orders one security staff member enters
and neutralizes D act recovering a CP
209 still in its empty State
okay that about does it for today folks
thank you very much for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tibor ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on smaller cool stuff as well as
it patreon.com forward slash the volcan
thank you
[Music]
you